коли вона заходить до супермаркету то аж
ніяк не за
покупками Селіна Юль обличчя данської
ініціативи проти марнування продуктів
харчування не можна їсти продукти після
завершення терміну їхньої придатності
Зовсім інша справа мінімальний термін
зберігання запам'ятайте після цього
строку харчі не стають
токсичними
коли Селіна Юль Переїхала з Росії до
Данії життя в так званому суспільстві
добробуту відкрило їй очі на цю
[музика]
проблему комунізм розвалився був дефіцит
їжі в магазинах гастрономи були фактично
порожні ми не марнували харчі бо їх не
було у нас панувала величезна повага до
їжі і коли я 24 роки тому приїхала до
Данії я побачила супермаркети і була
шокована кількістю їжі
8 років тому я заснувала Facebook групу
Stop fating Food Зараз ми найбільше У
даній організація з боротьби проти
маринування їжі лише на Фейсбуці у нас
63 000
підписників супермаркети або викидають
продукти або в найкращому випадку
переробляють
їх це наш біоконтейнер сюди надходять
продукти харчування які ми на жаль не
змогли продати з них виробляється біогаз
це природне тепло для
квартир на хвилі популярності економного
споживання з'являються крамниці
прострочених товарів тут багато
консервів але є й овочі клієнти в
захваті від низьких цін для таких
крамниць навіть дещо спеціально
виробляється так сусідня пекарня
навмисно готує більше випічки аніж
потрібно щоб решту замі мінімальну ціну
продати цьому
магазину виробництво харчових продуктів
шкідливе для довкілля наприклад для
виробництва та обробки сиру і м'яса
потрібні злакові вирощування яких
спричиняє великі викиди вуглекислого
газу кардинально змінити ситуацію могло
б зменшення виробництва їжі а не її
перерозподіл проте Данії вдалося зробити
Крок вперед тут стали значно менше
марнувати продукти харчування на
25%.
thane